welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series we are back again
with our fifth episode and I believe
we're gonna kick things off this time
with an announcement and what you have
here in the outline as a quote flex is
that is that the kind of content we're
putting out now we're just a flex a flex
Channel I guess well as a professional
in to physique sports I think flexing is
kind of within my domain yeah so the
announcement I haven't mentioned this on
anything in the stronger by science
universe yet but I recently became
involved with Eric Helms unfortunately
so Eric Helms and dr. Joe over at the
diet doc they recently started something
called the nutrition coaching global
mastermind and there's a board of people
on it and basically the members of the
board with dr. Joe and with with Eric
Helms we have these monthly roundtable
discussions about best practices and the
whole idea is to kind of unify the
nutrition coaching world and give some
guidance and some kind of professional
advice about not just the coaching
itself but also how to be an effective
nutrition coach whether it comes to the
way you interact with clients where you
get your information and how you run
your coaching business as well so I'm on
the board other people on the board
we've got Cory Propst Jennifer Sounders
Brian st. Pierre Gabrielle fund arrow
and Paul Ravel yeah some of those people
are doctors but I'm not that into titles
but a lot of really good people on the
board and if you're interested you can
go to nutrition coaching global comm and
find more information so that's the
announcement now the Flex a million
years ago I forget when we talked about
a study on the podcast and it was
looking at a placebo effect of an
imaginary low-calorie diet and it was
basically like we told these folks they
were on a low-calorie diet they weren't
they lost a ton of weight and when we
talked about it I basically saw the
title and I was like ooh this is
intriguing then I saw the stats and I
was like this is way less intriguing
than I thought and I talked about some
of the
coming statistically I don't recall
exactly how deep into the details we got
but I think we kind of just you know
talked about the highlights of the
statistical shortcomings turns out a
couple weeks ago somebody sent me on
Twitter a letter to the editor that was
written that basically talked about all
the stuff that we I'm pretty sure we
covered on the show and so here's the
take-home point if you want to stay up
to date with the literature that's an
excellent idea that's definitely a good
idea however if you want to be miles
ahead of the literature you need to be
listening to this podcast and somewhere
between our dating advice and our
fashion advice you're gonna find stuff
that is literally months ahead of the
literature so that's the flex works for
me
cool all right let's uh let's get into
just like the standard fireside chat
stuff just fun upbeat off-topic
conversations topics submitted by you
the listeners and one of the things
someone asked us was what fitness myths
are out there that we personally wish
were true do you want to kick this off
or do you want me to go first I would
love to kick this one off I have two of
them so the first one is that
supplements are super important
supplements when I was like 14 or 15 I
remember thinking that getting on a very
generic probably amino spiked protein
powder was going to really bring my
physique to the next level and I also
remember kind of judging a kid really
hard on my football team because he was
taking a no Xplode the original formula
that had creatine in it mm-hmm and we
were all like dude like we all want to
win but there are certain ethical
guidelines that we all need with like
let's do like is a run at state really
worth it if you have to sacrifice this
much in the process like think of your
health think of what you're going to
tell your kids when they see that you
know that championship ring and you have
to say yeah but it was you know fueled
by creatine dude I gotta say all of the
all of the creatine alarmism is some of
my favorite stuff ever yeah because like
the footnote
and all of those news stories are
absolutely wild where it's like you know
football player who had been taking
creatine kills over dead
you know the night after a big game and
then you find out on like paragraph 12
of the story that they went out like
binge drinking and had like 47 beers
like could you know could be creatine
poisoning could be alcohol poisoning one
of those we know for sure is real and
it's definitely creatine poisoning you
know yeah or it's like after the
football game they had a brain
hemorrhage true but did the creatine
contribute maybe it wasn't used to say
maybe it wasn't to concussions in a week
maybe it was the creatine I don't know
okay so that's one of them the other one
I really wish that genetics just didn't
matter that much like I remember as a
kid really never even considering like I
wonder if I'm built for this or I wonder
what what some of my limitations or
ceilings are gonna be and one thing I
think is really funny is I think a lot
of people I think sometimes people will
set the limit too low when they think
like oh I'm screwed my genetics are bad
and that sucks so I don't want it to be
like a limiting thing that is like you
know it takes the wind out of your sails
but I remember being younger thinking
like yeah I'm like maybe some of the
like top body bowlers in the world are
like on a ton of drugs but like if I
train hard enough for a long enough like
I'm sure I could be like 280 at 6% body
fat like I mean I'm doing the right
things and I like really believe that
for a while but the thing I find kind of
humorous about the the whole genetics
thing is like everyone who is super
salty on the internet and talks about
people being on steroids all the time
like you probably should be salty but it
probably has a lot more to do with jeans
than steroids so like every time you
know the people that it's like every
time there's a decent physique they go
in the comments and they're like oh it's
steroids and it's like you see that with
strength too like that there is a
subculture of people who believe that
like you know most people can probably
bench two plates naturally but like it's
probably it's probably PAH
possible for some genetic outliers to
bench 315 but there's like a 90% chance
here on gear if you bench three wheels
and for four plates like it's out of the
question like to do that naturally it
would take you know one in a trillion
genetics and odds are that's not you
right it's just like really though yeah
so it's like a it's like I wish I could
go back and believe that that genetics
just really wasn't a factor whatsoever
but I think some people take that a
little too far and they're like listen
if you're if you're squatting 405 you're
just an absolute freak you know so so I
I kind of hesitate to bring that one up
but yeah when I was it when I was a kid
like getting into it at like 14 I
thought with just the right supplement
combination and enough time literally
any physique can be obtained I wish I
could go back if I can just add some
commentary on top of that sure one of so
one of the talking points I see brought
up around this whole discussion a lot is
like you know these people on YouTube or
Instagram or whatever who maybe are
running gear maybe just have great genes
and they're like setting new lifters up
with false expectations for what to
expect and then like they're gonna
realize they can't get there and then
get demotivated and quit I just don't
know that I buy that literally at all so
like virtually everyone I know who's
been training for a long time like at
least a decade went into training with
completely ridiculous unrealistic
expectations yeah so my one of my first
introductions to powerlifting was it was
right after Andy Bolton set the squad
record I believe it was 12 13 pounds and
he had he had previously done the first
thousand pound deadlift maybe like three
months prior and I remember seeing that
and being like holy [ __ ] that's so cool
that's so much weight I didn't know
anything about equipped lifting I was
like well [ __ ] it I'm gonna deadlift a
thousand and squat 1200 like that that's
what
I was thinking for probably the first
like first like six months and then I
understood equip lifting better and I
was like well okay maybe a 1200 squad is
out of the picture but I hear deadlift
suits don't help that much so thousand
pound deadlift still for sure and maybe
I'll tone the squat down to like 900
yeah and yeah I mean it finally became
clear to me that I wasn't gonna hit
those numbers but like I don't give a
[ __ ]
training's still fun you know yeah yeah
I think like I said I really I very
distinctly remember a time when I was 19
I think and this is way too old to still
be thinking this I was 19 I had like a
good block of training like really was
starting to put on some muscle and I was
like should I shoot for should I try to
build up to like a good stout like 270
that was it I really had that I was like
I mean sure could I get fluffy maybe
balloon up to 12% body fat 270 sure I'll
cut it later
but I really thought I had like IFBB Pro
genetics and like whether or not I
happen to try some steroids along the
line was kind of immaterial so yeah I
mean but once I realized that that
wasn't gonna happen it's not like I was
like damn I've been lied to
I'm never gonna touch a weight again ya
know so I I'm like the poster child for
being fed false expectations because
early on so for like the first year or
so that I was into powerlifting I
trained with a crew of people and only
me and like one of the other dudes was
drug-free like everyone else was on was
on stuff and like they gave me advice as
if I wasn't drug-free and so I'm like
510 and they were like yeah like if 510
if you want to be competitive in
powerlifting you need to at least fill
out the 275 class so I mean so that's
completely delusional I feel like it's a
little bit less delusional
for me than you because I'm a little bit
taller than you are and have a slightly
larger frame but like I'd been to 75 and
it that's not a good [ __ ] look
there's a zero percent chance that I
could ever fill out anything
approximating to 75 without just being
incredibly fat but like it wasn't just I
was seeing it on social media because
like social media effectively didn't
exist back then YouTube was a thing but
like Scooby was the entirety of the
YouTube Fitness community but no like I
was being told that by people I knew and
trusted in person giving me like wildly
unrealistic expectations both about what
I would I might be able to lift
eventually and how much muscle I should
be able to build in what sort of weight
class I should be able to fill out so
like dude I was laboring under wildly
unrealistic expectations for a long time
and like it's fine you know like I look
back and I'm not upset I just think it's
funny yeah yeah so yeah I mean like like
I said I wish I could go back to
genuinely believing like add genetics
really don't factor in but but that's
not a not a an excuse to be like listen
you know my genetics are trash I should
just give up and never try you know yeah
so what about you what are some of the
fitness myths that you wish were true so
two are completely opposite and I wish
that they could simultaneously be true
one is that overtraining is a complete
and utter myth and the other one is kind
of like the Arthur Jones one set to
failure like once every 10 days is
sufficient to maximize muscle growth and
the reason I wish both of those things
were true is I like flexibility and
training and you know you know so at
different periods of time training means
different things to me so sometimes I've
registered for a meet and it's like okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill it for the next
like four to six months and try to put
up the biggest total possible and
sometimes it's like you know I have a
lot of work going on training isn't as
high of a priority I'm just gonna do a
little of it
to you know feel good and help maintain
sanity and if both of those myths were
simultaneously true I could like train
like a madman never over train
everything would be awesome and like
there there are times and there have
been periods of time in my life where I
wish my entire existence was just like
wake up eat breakfast go to the gym
train for four hours eat lunch go back
to the gym train for six hours eat
dinner go to bed like that sounds great
to me it's not feasible but uh yeah
so I wish overtraining was actually a
myth and so on the flipside I also wish
that one set to failure to maximize
muscle growth wasn't a myth so then you
know during times that I'm not training
as much and don't have as much time to
Train I could still get just as good of
results so like if both of those things
were true there would be a tremendous
amount of available flexibility in terms
of like optimal and workable training
parameters so that would be pretty sweet
and then the other one that I wish was
true so on the podcast before we both
talked about how for a period of time we
bought into the whole Kido thing right
oh yeah for sure
so I I wish that everything that was
promoted by like hardcore Kido files was
actually true that like as long as you
cut out carbs and kept insulin low and
like the carbohydrate insulin hypothesis
of obesity was a hundred percent
accurate but like you just cut out carbs
and you necessarily get shredded like
I've done that before I was pretty
strict keto for eight nine months I lost
like the initial like 510 pounds of
water weight that you do and lost I
don't know maybe another five pounds on
top of that over the entire period and
like that was that and and the thing is
like I kind of like keto so for me when
I think about foods that I crave
I don't really crave bread I don't
really crave sweets to me like the most
craveable food in existence is either
like
- brisket or like a well-cooked ribeye
or like slow-cooked beef ribs something
like that that's like very savory very
fatty very indulgent so like it sure
would be great if that was my entire
diet and I could get super lean in the
process so yeah that's that is a myth
that I very much wish was true you know
based on what you're describing have you
considered the carnivore diet is it
possible you just botched it and you
should have been on the carnivore diet
so when I was doing keto it was it was
effectively carnivore yeah cuz I was in
college and so I didn't have I didn't
have much money and so like the cheapest
protein source other than like tuna and
you know I don't want to just eat canned
tuna cuz you know there's there's
mercury and I don't want to rot my brain
right like I so I'm not trying to be
alarmist you can certainly eat some tuna
but I don't want to try to consume like
you know 300 grams of protein per day
from tuna that's right
probably not smart yes so I was just
living on a diet of bone-in skin-on
chicken thighs so I mean I I think like
the people who are really into carnivore
are really into like beef and steak yeah
but yeah like 80% of my calories were
bone-in skin-on chicken thighs
vegetables were too expensive I was not
eating vegetables so yeah it was it was
carnivore risk but yeah I don't know
cool well maybe you know if we keep
hoping that the science will come along
and improve that all those myths that we
held - maybe they are true that'd be
that'd be terrific but for now for now
it doesn't look like it another question
we got we've talked a little bit about
television and movies someone also asked
what music were into and I think you've
got a more detailed answer than me
yeah you so I'm gonna start yeah yeah so
I'm a huge Radiohead fan that's
something that Jeff Nippert and I have
bonded over is we both love radio
and there's really no casual Radiohead
fan it's like if you're if you like
Radiohead you really like them and and
yeah so Radiohead's probably my favorite
band ever buy a pretty comfortable
margin but another list of bands I like
it's kind of all over the place I mean
not not that far all over the place but
I like Interpol I like The Strokes who
just released a new album like a week
ago like The Black Keys especially some
of the album's they put out in the mid
to late 2000s were absolutely incredible
they did a junior Kimbrough cover album
that was sick
I like Wilco which is kind of like
alt-country which is pretty unique I
also like Rage Against the Machine and
what's really funny is I went to
Lollapalooza one year and they were
co-headlining so the the people that
were running Lollapalooza were like well
we'll have Wilco and Rage Against the
Machine play at the same time because
there is no crossover in that Venn
diagram of like yeah I like kind of folk
music alt-country and I also happen to
like Rage Against the Machine I was the
only person probably in the universe who
actually went to one half of the Wilco
show and then walked across the park to
catch the second half of the Rage show I
literally could not pick I like
Audioslave as well which is I mean
essentially the you know it's the rage
band Plus Chris Cornell Chris Cornell's
voice is insane absolutely incredible I
also like Dave Rawlings and Gillian
Welch they're like a kind of folk
country they often do things together as
a duo yeah so those are the bands I
listen to most frequently a little bit
of a range there but not quite the same
range that I'm seeing in your list so
why don't you take it away from here
yeah so now that I'm looking over this I
realize I probably shouldn't just read
all of these out yeah in the show notes
I can just include the full list there I
think I think that's a good way to do
this sure I don't want this to become
the podcast equivalent of the
Lillibridge training eBook
so here's here's a fun piece of like
power lifting content lore from like
circa 2013
so the Lillibridge is if you don't know
about them this is a tangent it's fine
so they're a family who are all
incredibly good power lifters Eric
little bridge has held the total world
record at 125 or 275 125 kilos and 308
or 140 kilos ernie Lillibridge jr. at
one time held the record at 198 or 90
kilos very very good
and then the father ernie senior has I
think he's held some master's records
you know he totals 1900 2000 plus and
he's like 50-something so all very very
good lifters they put out an e-book that
was I think it was just called the
Lillibridge method this was at like the
height of their fame in the powerlifting
community and you know everyone was
interested in how they trained so
they're like we're gonna put this
together in an e-book and drop it on the
masses and so the thing is I'm I'm not
going to make any judgments about
whether their program was good because I
mean clearly it was good enough for them
they're all [ __ ] strong but when the
e-book came out it got memed on pretty
heavily because the e-book itself was
like it was either 14 or 17 pages it was
one of the two the actual program was
like five of those pages almost half of
the pages were just like full-color
photos of like one of the members of the
family lifting and then I think the last
three pages of the book were like hey if
you're gonna be doing this program
you're gonna be lifting heavy you're
gonna be going hard you need music
that's loud enough and aggressive enough
to be able to fuel your train so the
last like three pages were just like
music suggestions and it was all it was
all like popular hard rock bands so in
the interest of not doing that on the
podcast will include the full list and
the show notes but some of the high
points for me my for favor
bands have been my four favorite bands
since like 2004 and their rise against
an berlin yellow card and silverstein so
you know that should tell you a little
bit about what kind of like mental state
I was in what kind of crowd I ran in
when I was approximately that age but
yeah they still [ __ ] slap they're
great we so I think the only only
musical act that we share between our
two lists is I'm also very interest the
Machine
the only other like pretty hard band
that I still listen to quite a bit is
Lamb of God I haven't really listened to
any of their newer stuff but their
albums sacrament is is fantastic I love
it
in terms of like kind of mainstream
music I've said this before publicly and
I don't think people actually believe me
I UNAC ly love post Malone you do it's
true dude post Malone's awesome let's
see I really like early Bo be really
into Daft Punk I really like borns and
churches so kind of like electronic type
music in terms of like some slightly
less popular acts so going along with
rise against an berlin yellow card also
really into saya sin' they recently got
back together their new stuff is quite
good a group that I think like people
into hip hop know about that people not
into hip hop don't know about is run the
jewels [ __ ] love run the jewels
so another artist that probably everyone
in the UK knows about that no one
outside the UK knows about is storm Z so
he's a UK based rapper really like his
stuff like some older music as well so
really like Billy Joel really like Elton
John really like Earth Wind and Fire and
then probably realistically the stuff I
listen to the most so I'll just like put
this on when I'm working is you know
because it doesn't have vocals so it's
not going to distract me is I really
like classical guitar music so
john williams is maybe the best
classical guitarist ever not the john
williams who did the Star Wars
soundtrack but another John Williams
Andres Segovia
old-school master and then for more
modern stuff Andy McKee is really really
good
and I also listened to a lot of just
like general synth wave because it's you
know it's chill vibes put it on when I'm
working so yeah
fairly eclectic mix but yeah that's
that's what I'm into it's interesting
because I'm looking at the full list and
one of the people you didn't mention you
actually listed twice so there's quite a
conflict brewing in your mind here who
was it you put Kanye twice and you
didn't mention him did I you did no well
that was an accident I mean I like Kanye
in I don't know so I feel like I feel
like my musical tastes have shifted this
is so they go through phases and I
mostly just like the artists stuff that
they put out when I initially got into
them like Kanye I really liked his early
stuff I don't really like his current
stuff but apparently his current stuff
is quite good and like people seem to
like it
so so one of the other ones where I kind
of like their early stuff considerably
more and I think this is much less
controversial is Eminem so I Eminem's
most recent album was pretty good but
really everything up to the Eminem show
was great everything between The Eminem
Show and his most recent album was
pretty mad like there were some good
tracks but it wasn't his best but yeah I
mean I don't know dude I just I just
like music and it kind of depends kind
of depends what mood I'm in now do you
believe that you really is it really
your choice to select what kind of music
you listen to do you think that's
predetermined so that's a Kona success a
good segue um we we had different
opinions about the quality of that segue
yeah we did so we talked previously on
the show about Deb's which recently
ended and we're not getting give away
any spoilers because that's way too
recent to do that
but one of the themes that comes up in
the show is that of determinism and Greg
you mentioned you wanted to talk about
this on the show and I literally know
nothing about it
other than the fact that I've watched
Deb's so I'm gonna let you kind of steer
the ship here and then I will either
agree or disagree or maybe form my own
kind of school of philosophical Wow on
the fly yeah so I I'm not just like
putting this forward this is something
that listeners ask about so I mean you
mentioned you don't have like a
philosophical commitment one way or the
other here mm-hmm
but you have watched EV correct and I
know you consume little enough media
that you have the headspace to actually
think about the media you consume so if
that is like your only point of
reference how do you just personally gut
instinct feel about the concept of
determinism like as a definition or
whether or not it seems like a valid
school of thought more so the latter
okay so my my initial thoughts
I guess the can you can you give like an
operational definition yeah so it's so
like philosophical determinism is
basically the idea that kind of the
world around us is as it seems like
every effect is brought about by prior
causes you know nothing is caused that
doesn't have a prior effect and causes
determine effect so you know you can
have like a a to B to C to D to e
sequence of events such that so an
implication of determinism which this is
literally impossible because of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle but if
there was a way to to know the positions
and states of every particle in the
universe at any given point in time if
you had all of that information and you
knew it perfectly then you could predict
going back in time everything that has
ever happened and going forward
everything that ever will happen and
there's there's some there's some nuance
to that so
you know you could then get into a
discussion of are we living in a single
world or do we believe in like the multi
world hypothesis but classical
determinism is basically that I di put
forth okay
now before I answer this I want to make
one thing very clear someone might be
listening and thinking wow these two
weightlifting people you know the
bodybuilder and the power lifter fancy
themselves as philosophers now I am
coming at this from the perspective of
an intellectual dumbass I'm not so if
you're like cringing thinking oh great
Eric's taking on philosophy not at all
the case I don't understand any of this
however I will have an opinion but
that's pretty much where I'm at as well
okay good yeah because I could imagine
somebody being like oh god here they go
you know I don't know I'd like to
believe that there's like freewill and
choices that occur that are not purely
predetermined oh so so that is worth
mentioning like I think a lot of people
they hear about the concept and they're
like yeah the laws of physics seem to
function reasonably well sure we live in
a deterministic world but a logical
implication of at least like strict
classical determinism is that free what
free will is an illusion yeah yeah so I
am unless you're a [ __ ] compatibilist
and I'm sure there's gonna be compatible
lists in my DMS who are really mad at me
about this I don't understand
compatibilism and if you don't know what
compatibilism is that's fine we're not
going to discuss it because it's it's
confusing and I don't think it makes
sense well people are going to very
forcefully help you understand it in
your DMS it sounds like yeah I'm gonna
say like I think that I still think
there's that little bit of uncertainty
that I think is is influenced by by
people making choices you know having
free will to do so so I feel like if
you're talking about like is this stuff
all kind of you know that idea of if you
know the state of all these things can
you then like predict or
act track with with perfect accuracy I
think you could get really damn close
but I don't think it would be perfect I
think there are these these key that key
element of freewill and choices that
people make at their own volition that
is inherently not it cannot be predicted
perfectly that that would be my my
answer so a determinist answer to that
would be like okay like maybe we can't
predict things perfectly that very well
could be a matter of either a just not
having enough information to do so right
or be you know possibly like a mini
world's cosmology of like we would need
to basically predict like a branching
series of everything that could happen
because like quantum weirdness who
splits the universe every time the a
wavefunction collapses so yeah I don't
know yeah I'm gonna give myself the very
pleasent narrative that I have total
control over everything I do and I have
freewill and it's great so here's the
question what is a decision
fundamentally like on a physical basis
on a physical basis yeah it's all the
little neurons you know hanging around
with all the little neurotransmitters
you jostle it around a little bit you
get a decision yeah so it's something
that has to do with you know a physical
substrate brain tissue or if you think
that like consciousness isn't fully
housed in the brain the mind if you will
if that's the analogy you prefer but I
mean ultimately if you think that it has
something to do with brain function and
neurotransmitters etc that's still in
outcome of a physical system and like
virtually every physical system that
we're aware of behaves under
deterministic principles so why why is
your brain different I don't know I
don't really know how brains work I try
not to think too hard about it yeah and
so so that that is actually one of the
complications here
no one [ __ ] knows how brains work
yeah that's so that's what I mean that's
probably too broad of a statement like
we know a lot about how brains work but
it's not like there's a fully
functioning model of a human brain that
we can like use to predict brain
function super super accurately right um
so so yeah like I I certainly think that
this is an open question so my so I I do
actually buy the idea of classical
determinism and I want to make it clear
that that's not like that's not like an
intransigent philosophical commitment
that's at the core of my being that I
could not possibly be convinced
otherwise of yeah so I you know it's not
it's not like a commitment that I hold
super strongly but for me at least I
kind of view I kind of view it as like a
reasonable null hypothesis yeah that
like we don't know everything about how
brains work we don't know everything
about how the human mind functions but
we know a hell of a lot about how
physical systems function generally they
all seem to basically be deterministic
unless you're dealing with like quantum
weirdness but like unless you're
positing that there's some sort of like
higher aspect of humanity that is like
then controlling the collapse of the
wave functions [ __ ] going on in your
neurons in your brain that like then can
robustly make decisions while still
adhering to strict determinism I don't
know that just seems weird that seems
like it violates Occam's razor like
you're you're proposing more [ __ ] to
explain something that should be able to
be explained considerably easier so yeah
like to me until we gather more data
like a strict deterministic view of the
world seems like a relatively useful
null that I haven't seen super strong
evidence against and like I said a an
implication of that is that free will
doesn't exist which is like a really
trippy idea that I think people have a
hard time
rapping their brains around yeah I don't
know like I'm kind of comfortable with
it oh I don't think I am I like either
having free will or pretending I do yeah
I mean I think people like to have the
well I don't know do people like the
idea that they own their decisions so
typically they do and so I had okay so
we mentioned at the top of this segment
that that neither of us are philosophers
by by any definition of the term right
the only fly I have a doctor of
philosophy but that is true yeah so the
only philosophy that I do actually have
formal training in that I took like
actual classes for is moral philosophy
so I do know a little bit more about
that I don't profess myself to be an
expert by any means but like I you I get
the foundations of that better and so I
had I had some some ethical quandary
about whether I wanted to discuss this
on the podcast in general because one of
the things about the determinism
discussion and specifically discussions
of does Free Will exists or not is the
outcomes of of telling people that they
don't have free will has been studied
like in in laboratory settings before
where essentially you you have two
groups of people one of them you have
like you expose them to information or
like have them read passages about how
like free well exists and like moral
choices are are a thing versus another
group where you expose them to
information about how free well it
doesn't exist it's all an illusion the
concept of choice is a farce and
essentially like the world is playing
out around you you do what you were
always going to do and like what you
perceive to be choices basically just
like an evolutionary mechanism to keep
you from going crazy yeah so you expose
people to those two different narratives
and then you put them in some sort of of
scenario where they're forced to make a
moral choice and the people who believe
in
four you will then go on to make what is
what would typically be construed as the
more ethical choice yeah whereas people
who think free well is is an illusion
behave at least on average statistically
speaking less ethically yeah so I guess
that doesn't actually speak to whether
people like the idea free will or not
but it at least says something about how
people behave when they no longer
believe in it or at least like believe
less strongly in it yeah if they've been
exposed to the kind of yeah
counter-argument right before that
particular test is done yeah so so like
for example I'm like I said I am a
little bit ethically conflicted about
whether or not we should have talked
about this on the podcast because yeah
you know maybe this becomes a brain worm
in some of our listeners heads and they
start behaving less ethically I don't
know one saying free will exist that
that's your you can worry about that I'm
quite no yeah yeah I mean fair enough
yeah so you know I decided eventually
with that caveat we gave at the top of
this section of discussion neither of us
are [ __ ] experts you shouldn't trust
me like we're just two dude shooting the
[ __ ] here
yeah however I would be incredibly
uncomfortable with someone going on
national television and having the same
discussion because whether or not Free
Will exists and whether or not
determinism is true I kind of think
society would function better if you
know if everyone still kept believing
free well existed like I think that
whether or not this is true or false
there would be bad outcomes of fewer
people believing in free will
are you ethically conflicted about Debs
talking about the topic um I kind of
just don't think enough people will get
it yeah it doesn't matter that much
and also like media is so fragmented now
yeah but there's a difference between
you know devs which is like a nice show
on a single platform that not everyone
subscribes to and certainly not everyone
will
watch the show it's it's one thing for
them to discuss it it would be totally
different for like Tom Brokaw - to have
disgusted 20 years ago you know yeah I
mean like I said I'm quite skeptical I
just think yeah I think you could get a
pretty good predictive model going where
you'd be like okay we've got this mostly
sorted out but I just I can't get over I
can't let go of the idea that there are
other factors at play other than just
like pure determinism as I understand it
which is admittedly quite poorly well so
so like I said so hopefully this isn't
like too big of a spoiler for devs like
if someone watches it they'll figure
this out by like episode three well one
of the things going on in the show is
basically they have a computer that that
they at least think can perfectly
project everything that's ever happened
and project forward everything that will
happen that right that's kind of like
you know it's a surprise when you learn
it in like Episode three but it's that's
not like the big twist of the show or
anything so not too big of a spoiler so
like I alluded to at the top of this
discussion functionally that's
impossible the reason why is the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle you
can't know the position and momentum
I believe it's either yeah yeah I think
its position in momentum but you can't
know the position and momentum of a
particle at the same time that by
measuring the position like you affect
the momentum and so then your momentum
reading is wrong and so yeah
functionally you could never perfectly
know the state of you know the system of
the universe every particle at a single
point in time so the that whole concept
is literally impossible so yeah there
will never be at least based on what we
know about physics now there will never
be like a perfect test right of whether
determinism is true or false because it
would be impossible to build a system
similar to the one in devs right yeah so
yeah I think it's you know just
something fun to stew on and think about
yeah yeah I mean it's it's interesting
to think about some of these ideas and
like well what would that mean like
where the implicit
of that you know just trying to make
sense of the world around you as is a
fun trip if you've got some time on your
hands I suppose so one one implication
that I think is is fairly obvious or at
least something to consider is okay so
if determinism is true free will is an
illusion then it might be worth thinking
about how we would approach say the
criminal justice system and just all of
that so if free will is true then people
who commit crimes or you know do heinous
things they made a choice to do that
maybe that was influenced by their genes
maybe that was influenced by their
environment and upbringing but like
ultimately at the point of committing a
crime they made they made a choice to do
something that's either wrong or at
least illegal right and so then then
then you then that brings about the
ethical discussion like you know
are you into deontology are you into
teleology like you know is it worth a
punitive approach to criminal justice
where like they did something bad they
need to be punished for it or even if
you still believe in free will you could
say like well okay maybe we'll have
better societal outcomes if we take a
rehabilitative approach whatever there
may or may not be that syllable there
yeah so so you can have the the ethical
discussion of what's the best way to
treat this but you can at least make an
argument for a punitive approach to
criminal justice because someone made a
bad choice and maybe they should be
punished for it if you don't accept that
Free Will exists then they basically do
what they were always going to have done
they didn't make a moral or ethical
choice to do something badder like
specifically choose to break the law
that's that is something that was always
going to happen right and so then you
really can't make an argument for a
punitive criminal justice system unless
unless a punitive criminal justice
system has better societal wide results
which
it doesn't seem to right so then like it
would seem fairly obvious at the whole
point of Criminal Justice is well okay
something about these people made them
or like yeah like made them do something
that was bad that we don't like so then
the whole point of criminal justice is
to try to basically change how their
brain is wired so that when they are let
out they won't do it again
and so then then the whole point becomes
like you know how can we make them
behave in a more pro-social way when
they get out again versus how do we
punish them for this thing that they
chose to do right
heavy stuff to think about it is yeah
how about some lighter stuff how about
some lighter stuff alright so you
brought a challenge to my attention that
I had never heard of you said it's
called the Florida man challenge and I
guess the premise is you google Florida
man and then your birthday right yeah so
yeah go ahead and so the background here
is when you say Florida man to a lot of
people that will immediately conjure an
image of a news story where someone you
know 99% of the time a man hints Florida
man did something wild and it was
reported in the news and so there's this
whole idea I think that like Florida is
hotting it is basically like the Mad Max
universe like uniquely like there's
crazy stuff happening yeah exactly
and so the Florida man challenge kind of
takes that on board and like a Florida
man's done something crazy on every day
of the year so just google Florida man
and your birthday and see what someone
crazy in Florida did on your birthday so
you did the Florida man challenge what
was um oh there was there was one I
don't remember exactly but there was one
about a very drunk person doing
something with big like something with
spaghetti at Olive Garden right yeah one
second let me get this pulled up or I'll
give mine and you google it again so you
can get like the exact headline
yeah okay so the one for my birthday was
Florida man tased by police after
refusing to get out of Walmart ceiling
and so essentially a guy went into
Walmart decided to like crawl up into
the ceiling and refused to get out those
those wild Florida people pretty crazy
while you're still looking for yours I
got mine I got mine okay drunk shirtless
Florida man arrested after shoveling
spaghetti in his mouth at Olive Garden
right yeah and so one of the one of the
great things about Florida man stories
is like often these headlines raise a
lot of questions so like they're good to
click on and I think this is the whole
reason that this that this genre of
journalism exists cuz like journalism
and like the whole internet runs on
clicks and traffic and so you you read
that headline and you're like dude
people eat spaghetti at Olive Garden how
could he have possibly been eating
spaghetti so poorly that the cops were
called but here's another one for my
birthday okay song wearing Florida man
arrested while building shed with
garbage on strangers property so I think
that was actually a couple days earlier
so that I had that one pulled up as well
for my wife's birthday yeah what came up
for me okay so and that's another one it
asks it makes you ask so many questions
so one what the [ __ ] is in the water in
Florida want to why is this guy wearing
a thong three
why is he building a shed on his
neighbor's or on a dangerous property
and four how does one even build a shed
out of garbage I don't know so it's it's
wonderful clickbait and so this this is
a whole thing and there is this concept
on the internet and I don't know how
many people actually believe this but I
feel like it's a plurality if not a
majority that like what is going on down
in Florida you know something got into
the water and just everyone in Florida
is is just batshit insane so yeah
there's that idea
I want to debunk it lightly a little bit
which is why I wanted to bring this up
on the podcast
so in in the US and I assume this is a
thing elsewhere as well there's a
concept of sunshine laws and so the idea
behind sunshine sunshine laws is to make
government function more transparent so
whenever the government does stuff and
like generates documents there then
accessible to people and so they're I
believe as a nationwide sunshine law a
lot of states have their own sunshine
laws a lot of official documents
generated within your state you can get
your hands on either in like you know a
county by county database or a statewide
database or if something isn't if
something isn't easy to find you can at
least get it via Oya request and the
thing about florida's Sunshine Law is
that it went on the books reasonably
early and it's very it's very lenient
like you can get your hands on a lot
more documents and I believe that
they're organized in a way that is that
makes them more searchable and easily
accessible and so I wouldn't be shocked
if the median Floridian is a little bit
wilder than like the median resident of
another state but it's not as big of a
difference as it probably seems so if
you think about those headlines right if
someone says a Florida man did XYZ
necessarily that means that either it's
someone outside the state writing about
it or at someone inside the state
writing about it to garner clicks
outside of the state so like for example
we live in North Carolina we live in
Raleigh
if someone in Raleigh did something
weird and wacky the the Raleigh
what's our paper called Raleigh News and
Observer one of them yeah yeah so the
Raleigh News and Observer wouldn't run a
headline that says North Carolina man
does whatever like it would say like
local man does XYZ right the Durham
newspaper wouldn't say North Carolina
man did whatever Raleigh man does XYZ
and so if the have a headline that has
Florida man in it is not informed
at all to people who live in Florida
yeah it would say local person or like
the city they live in
and so essentially this is a genre of
news that was generated by Florida
having in early Sunshine Law in the
books that that makes their documents
very easily searchable and accessible
and so it kind of became like a genre of
great clickbait very very early in the
game and so like I said I think more
states do have laxer sunshine laws now
but it's just like the freeze Florida
man has so much cultural purchase
already it kind of becomes like a
self-perpetuating thing that journal is
outside of Florida know that like man if
I want a crazy story that's gonna get
clicks let's just search these public
records and like arrest databases in
Florida because there is bound to be
gold in them hills whereas like you know
it wouldn't immediately come to mind to
do that for some other state that has a
Sunshine Law that is similar to
Florida's ya know Florida its nickname
is the Sunshine State
and yeah is it safe to assume that
that's why they're called sunshine laws
you know if this was a news and current
event park assed I would have done more
research I'm gonna look into that I
don't I don't think so
I think sunshine laws existed prior to
Florida's sunshine law interesting well
that's a weird coincidence what is
called the Sunshine State you've heard
that right yeah I have yeah but I mean I
tell you what this is a huge relief to
me because I know people in Florida I
work with people in Florida and it is
great to hear that this is just kind of
an artifact of the way the laws and the
journalism works you know cuz I was
worried but but now I feel much much
better yeah so yeah so looking at this I
believe the first sunshine law may have
been passed federally in 1976 in
Florida's at least like Florida's
current version passed in 91 man that's
why yeah I I don't know if I don't know
if Florida's was
I don't think Florida had one predating
the federal one I'm not totally sure how
that works but it is essentially so like
I said I do kind of assume that there is
more wild and wacky stuff going on in
Florida than say like Idaho maybe but
it's probably not too as extreme of an
extent as the average citizen assumes
because it is at least partially it is
at least partially an artifact of how
journalism works and how the sunshine
laws work well that is very interesting
I'm sure a lot of people are gonna be
surprised to hear that debunked or or at
least partially debunked yeah sure
all right well I think that does it for
today's episode Greg you're the host of
the show tell everybody what they need
to hear at the end of an episode yeah so
if you're listening to this on whatever
any podcast platform go rate us if you
like the show if you don't like the show
don't rate it please if you're watching
on YouTube like comment subscribe
hate myself every time I say that gonna
keep saying it if you are interested in
asking a question either for a fireside
chats of something fun light off topic
like philosophical determinism or food
stuff or music stuff or anything else
you can find the Q&A forum to do that at
tiny dot CC /sb sqa if you have
questions about anything Fitness related
you can ask using the same form but
unfortunately way more fitness questions
have been coming in than off-topic
questions so yeah if there's just like
anything random you want us to talk
about use that form tiny dot CC / SBS QA
hope life is treating you well hope
everything is going well and we'll talk
to you again soon thanks for listening
to the stronger by science podcast now
Greg and I are not experts in medicine
or health or really anything else for
that matter so before you make any
changes to your diet and exercise habits
make sure you check with a doctor or
another healthcare professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you